you know when you got scrubs obviously
you i i didn't believe this but i mean i
believe it
but six times you auditioned for it is
that true yeah but but
you know that's a lot like that's i mean
i can understand you go in they want to
see you again and they want you to test
but that six times i mean what did they
want to see
what did they want to see from zach
braff well that's a very good question
i think um i was a waiter
and i had no i didn't have many credits
i had only done a handful of things
but i had nothing they could really look
at and be like oh he'd just been on this
show
and i was up against a couple of known
people
um that i won't say but i'll tell you
off the air and so i was like i was kind
of like i'm never gonna get this they're
gonna give it to one of these known guys
but so i but then i kept getting called
back and then
i got called back again and then it was
like a work session with bill the show
runner and then it was
uh then it was okay we want to see a
chemistry review and sarah chalk had
already been cast
and then it was then you know how the
end goes you then go in front of the
studio
apparently they're not doing this like
they used to back in in our day when we
got going but
for those listeners who don't know when
you go to the studio
a studio test you would then go in front
of like
10 to 20 people and it was so
intimidating
and then if you pass that round you'd
then go to the network
where there could be i mean i remember
for scrubs it was probably 25 people
packed in a small room
and and all staring at me and it's like
i remember thinking it's like the
olympics like it doesn't matter how well
you did it at home it's like you do it
now or you die
and uh and it's a ludicrous process
because i never understood
why you're making the actors sweat so
hard they're not auditioning to be in a
broadway show
you know where they have to perform live
in front of me they're auditioning to be
a an actor that's great on set that that
cuts together well
right so why not now at least when i've
done pilots in latter years there's more
like okay
we'll look at the tape we don't need to
we don't need to have you come in and
and do this in a tiny room in front of
30 people and
so much pressure well it worked out yes
it did how many seasons was it
i did nine we we did nine yeah good god
i left a little bit early so i sometimes
i did eight and a half but the we did
nine now
obviously you've directed a ton you did
you know directed the 100th episode you
directed i don't know what
30 episodes 20 episodes no no not that
many actually i
thought it was more too and i recently
went back and looked and i think i only
did like seven or so
do you remember when you first directed
an uh episode of scrubs
were you really worried about it's like
now you're directing these people you've
been working with
and that's that's scarce because you
want to make them think he knows what
he's doing
do you remember that first day or yeah i
had done i had tiptoed in because
here's my tiptoe in was um well first of
all
bill pretty much made fun of me like a
big brother our our show
our showrunner creator has since become
one of my best friends and he's a mentor
to me
but at the time we had a very big
brother little brother relationship
he was supportive of me and he loved me
but he was tough on me
and um i think he had an interest
it seems well he's admitted in the past
of sort of keeping my ego in check
because he didn't want to have a
a kid who'd become super famous and
cocky and ruin his life
um so he would do things to bring me
down a notch and
i remember that the line producer said
that i could direct the music video
for this theme song um
and i thought that was so exciting and
bill sort of made fun of me he said
something to quip like
oh well that should make sure no one
ever sees it
and i really felt like and he did
in front of the crew
and and
i did it and i i said to myself i need
to crush this i need to crush this to
not only show him up and give him the
finger
but also so that the so that the cast
will trust me so i could one day direct
an episode so i just put everything i
had into it and i made a really cool
music video which
i haven't seen in years but you could
check out if you're curious on youtube
and um and then what happened was garden
state this was roughly 2003 then garden
state
happened and garden state had a
record sale at sundance and then he had
to he had to
sort of eat crow and change his whole
tune and then he was like okay
you can direct an episode